[Music]
[Music]
homeys legends lend me our ears
how you livin it is the lef koe I know
you said it for me so I appreciate you
how is everybody doing
how you livin how you feel I hope you
guys enjoyed travel gains the other day
the man's hit me up he says that you
guys are sending him so many messages he
doesn't even realize what's going on he
told me and this is word-for-word
I love the 33% I love the homeys you
guys are making this podcast frickin
huge because every time I get a freaking
guest on now they go so many the homies
are hitting me up and I just want you
guys to know now that I'm like messaging
athletes to try and do stuff with them
they know because of y'all so I
appreciate you to every home that is
joining in on the eat like a homie
challenge love y'all love y'all we are
this is gonna be day three or for some
of you if you did it Tuesday Wednesday
and this is gonna come out on Thursday
so it will be day number three
date number four for me fatal flaw I
forgot to weigh myself and I already
feel like I've lost like 20 pounds no
but I'm I'm not gonna weigh myself I'm
just gonna do this because I want to be
healthy and that's something I want to
say to all you guys again I'm not gonna
force this down anybody's throat but a
lot of you are saying what are we doing
what are we giving up what are we not
eating homies that you know what healthy
is this ain't we're all giving up
something whatever you think I screams
probably not it
you know like fried chickens probably
not in it so just be smart that's all
we're doing we're not giving up anything
we're not we're just gonna be smart and
the other thing is too if you got a
moment of weakness like yesterday I was
at a restaurant that had a bread bowl
that would have knocked you on your ass
and it took all of my strength not to
eat one of them rolls if you do it's
okay man like just get back at it
tomorrow as a chubby fat guy talking to
all the homies out
there i'm raka would shoe cuz i know
what this shit's like and a lot of
people are saying I want to work out
with travell gains how do I enter take a
picture of you on the scale like looking
down at your weight cuz I know like the
other thing that sucks is like nobody's
trying to send me before pictures and to
be honest no offense I'm not really
trying to see before pictures if you
want to take one great and take that
before-and-after awesome my only other
thing too is if y'all could wear socks
when you take the picture I would
appreciate that I'm not sure I look at
everybody's feet and the other thing is
is if you want to write your name on
your socks as proof so while you guys
aren't going on Google Images and
finding random people on scales so take
if you want to write like your name or
your handle and the socks also don't
send them to me now cuz I'm just gonna
forget them so when the 33 days are up
you send them in there we'll see how
you're doing but the whole point of this
is I'm trying to be healthy let's
everybody get healthy and then this
summer we're just like shredded football
knowing machines coming up in a little
bit we have oh by the way go I have so
excited to do what I'm about to do but
Kevin by Yard all-pro safety from the
Tennessee Titans if you remember when I
was in Atlanta for a little bit I'm
gonna be gone next week too so I got
three interviews that I'm saving for you
guys and now I'm ready to release him to
you
today will be Kevin by yard all-pro
safety we talked about him posing on the
star if you remember that game on
Thursday night I think it was or Monday
night
Titans Cowboys he posed on the star what
it was like to be an all-pro Mariota
very good conversation that's coming up
in a bit and then next week Austin
Hooper with one of the best
conversations I've had the tight end for
the Falcons you're gonna love this guy
and you guys know that my pro player
comparison for the longest time was who
Algie Crumpler big body possession over
the middle I did not know he was coming
in an interview with algae Crumpler and
I got to talk to him about that Brian
Dawkins hit that removed every ounce of
his soul we
laughed about it we yelled about it it
was great so those are coming up next
week
I think tight ends might be my spirit
animal because the conversations with
those guys were great one thing that
wasn't great you know look guys I've
been running the left ghost show social
Instagram Twitter and so when you see me
comment on my own [ __ ] don't make fun of
me bro I'm just trying to keep this
thing alive but I saw something in the
comment section that really upset me and
I can't believe that happened I saw it
and it broke me into my core and I don't
even remember where it is I couldn't
find it just now but somebody wrote
r.i.p whoa big offseason and fellas
ladies it stopped me in my tracks
because I rent holy [ __ ]
I've been doing these interviews and I
know that y'all been liking them and I
hope that you like them but I'm missing
out on the number one thing that this
show is based on so I am now ready to
give you a super-sized version of what
hit that music Nick
big offseason shout-out to audio Nick
shoutout to stinky fingers Gabe they
were in a booth and they just started
yelling well oh Allah it is back it is
whoa big offseason here's what we're
doing though a lot of stories I had to
catch up on some of these are whoa big
offseason and some of these are whoa big
offseason because some of these are real
and some of these are just woes so we're
gonna start off with a whoa big
offseason
Joe Flacco this is a tweet from Ryan
Konigsberg in Denver
Joe Flacco just overthrew a guy that was
seven oh I went to the wrong camera hole
and Nick go with me again ready whoa big
Huff season Joe Flacco overthrew a guy
that was 70 yards down the field can see
I've ever seen that around here before
whoa big offseason you mean to tell me
that Joe Flacco can throw the ball far
that's never been the issue also you're
in Denver but man I don't know if Drew
locks gonna be the quarterback of the
future because Joe Flacco is out here
throwing some bombs
that's a whoa now whoa big offseason
apparently the Jets GM is being assisted
by Peter Schrager the New York Jets are
reaching out to good morning football
reporter Peter Schrager and Maneesh met
has been all over this turning to him
for opinions suggestions and intel on
who the GM could be this is wild to me
this is to me the bottom that the Jets
have reached and this is not an insult
to Peter Schrager who is a great guy but
the fact that it seems like the Jets
have gotten rid of an internal search
committee and are instead going to a
reporter to help them find their next GM
feels like crazy pills to me is Adam
GaSe you know how Donald Trump watches
Fox and Friends every morning and that's
where he gets his news
does Adam GaSe have a TV where they
can't find the remote and NFL Network's
on and he has to watch good morning
football and he's sitting there going
I'll tell you what miss Peters Reger
know some things this to me if I was a
Jets fan is of all the things that have
happened
Anthony Barr spurning you at the last
moment and going back to Minnesota
firing some scouts recently stories
coming out that Adam GaSe never wanted
levy on bail Adam GaSe publicly saying
on just the coach but also secretly
manipulating everybody in the front
office of all the things the fact that
they're turning to Peter Schrager for
their GM search again not a slate to
Peter Schrager is one of the scariest
things I've ever heard if I was a Jets
fan undoubtedly a whoa big offseason
whoa big offseason Derek Carr on being
the quarterback for the Raiders quote
the owner head coach team and
quarterback are all in the same page
this is my team and I'm not going
anywhere
followed it up by saying what was the
percentage chance the Raiders would have
drafted a quarterback he put it at
negative 47 hey Derek your backup
quarterbacks
are Mike Glennon Landry Jones and oh no
I read that right Nathan Peterman no
[ __ ] you're the quarterback Derek I'm
glad you got job security like that is
the the funniest backup room I've ever
heard Mike Glennon pick six Mike Glennon
pick six Nathan Peterman and Landry
Jones who once said he thought about
quitting football to become a minister
or your backups you're good oh I'm glad
you got job security whoa
alright now I'm gonna get serious Nick
apparently miles Garrett was told by
former defensive coordinator Greg
Williams now New York Jets defensive
coordinator of piling on there Greg
Williams that he was only allowed to use
to pass rushing moves last season he was
told these are the ones that work don't
use any other ones
and miles Garrett's was like what am I
supposed to do the reason this is a whoa
is new defensive coordinator Steve
Wilkes formerly the Arizona Cardinals is
gonna let him unleash the bag if miles
Garin had that kind of a season last
year and could only use two moves what
are we about to witness the hype in
Cleveland continues to build I need to
get miles Garin on this show I'm gonna
hit him up if you guys want to reach out
to him I'd appreciate it
whoa big offseason Sam Beale second-year
player from the Giants was taken the
compensatory draft last year didn't play
an entire snap though has apparently
looked great at OTAs this is right in
the whoa big offseason wheelhouse why
did he look great because on one play
reporters got a chance to watch practice
and he stuck out his hand and swatted an
Eli Manning pass and it was intercepted
by Jabril peppers quote from Biel I'm
gonna read it how he said it I just seen
the quarterback staring him down quote
I've got some good eyes intercepting
your own quarterback in practice is like
screen watching your friend picking
plays in Madden it's like playing
Goldeneye and you use that little
[ __ ] whose name I can add job
and you're looking at the other people's
screen to find where they set the
proximity mines and you're in practice
bro you know all the plays you know
exactly the routes and where they're
trying to go and to make matters worse
you know these New York teams are
cracking me up
he's already nicknamed the secondary the
new and YPD the New York pass defense
solace a few years ago you know they had
up they a DRC they had generous the
current secondary of the Giants this
supposed New York past offense Sam Beal
Jabril Peppers Antoine Bethea generous
Jenkins
you don't get a nickname bro like you
can't call yourselves the new NYPD when
one of you I don't mean to insult
Antoine Bethea Angelo buffet is a great
player not a lot left in the tank jinora
Jenkins fell off a cliff last year but
if Sam bill and Jabril peppers are in
your secondary secondary you don't get a
cool nickname that's why you are a whoa
a big offseason this is one of the most
serious woes I've ever seen there are
some times that we get information that
can change the landscape of the NFL an
entire division the future of a
franchise and this one is about the
number one hundred hi this is so serious
that I don't want to [ __ ] it up but
apparently when asked what Sleep Number
mattress he uses Kirk Cousins uses a 100
quote I go as firm as it gets I'm an
intense even when I am sleeping
I vow I mean to my core I am shocked
we've just learned that the only thing
stiffer than Kirk Cousins is his
mattress but it shows you this is a guy
that counts pebbles outside of his house
to remind himself of his mortality he
sleeps on practically a slate 100
mattress are you a psychopath what I'm
realizing is is Kirk Cousins a vampire
does he measure himself because he's
watching other people die and in his
mind he can't handle this existence
anymore uh if if you have garlic do not
go around Kirk Cousins has anyone ever
seen Kirk Cousins reflection I haven't
now I'm a little bit worried Kirk
Cousins whoa
was really really scary I'm gonna stay
on the serious one
Jared vet no no no whoa big offseason
Jared Bell deer is retiring from the
Patriots yes that Jared Bell dear that
signed with the Patriots eight days ago
which brings up a lot of history and one
big question what the [ __ ] is going on
at Patriots practice that these esteemed
veterans after a very short time need to
hit the trail Reggie Wayne Patriot for a
few days
retires Eric Decker got through like a
preseason game retired wide receiver
Leonard Hankerson member he went to
Miami then was on Washington then I'm on
the Patriots in his Twitter bio says I
was a patriot for ten days lol and what
I'm realizing is how many of you start a
job and you go let me just get past the
first week it'll get better
Jared well dear Lestat eight days which
to me is holy [ __ ] this first week is
crazy showed up the next Monday and went
oh this is every [ __ ] day out to me
it's the only team where you see this
happen the Patriots are the only team
where these guys go I've waited my
entire career to finally play for Bill
Belichick in a Super Bowl champion they
go there for a short amount of time and
they're out Jared valdaire retires after
eight days is a super whoa but the thing
is is you can go wow this team lost
Trent Brown Wow their number one swing
tackle goes to the bills what and now
they're relying on Isaiah Wynn who
didn't even play last year I'm just
gonna say this like I always do if any
of you have a shred of doubt about Bill
Belichick and the Patriots you can see
yourself out and you can go and listen
to another podcast
there will be no doubting of Bill
Belichick on this podcast that is a
fool's errand we don't do that here and
so guess what there
find some hot dog salesman Dantes
Carnegie is gonna coach him up and
they'll be fine at left tackle cuz
that's what Bill Belichick does and we
end with this I know that a lot of you
right now are eating healthy you're
eating like a homie you're not the only
one NFL players getting in the mix you
know that we Loveland dews go vegan and
change that diet because that's what we
care about on the left coast show and
our guy
white boys Supreme Christian McCaffrey
little article in GQ we talked about his
diet apparently got some testing done my
man can't have chicken tuna wieder soy
damn but listen to know what this dude
does on Monday because it's a quote
straight linear explosive training day
all he has are egg yolks
so all the homies out there that are
eating healthy right now making him egg
whites ship your yolks to Christian
McCaffrey cuz this dude is [ __ ] rocky
drinkin egg yolks on a Monday you want
to know why his arms were so jacked
because this man is crushing yolks then
he said Saturday nights are cheat night
and he does love a little sushi but he
says his vices and I'm gonna tell you
that he may have listed and I'd love for
you guys to tell me if I'm wrong the two
best snack foods of all time and my
respect towards Christian McCaffrey
skyrocketed when I saw these because the
man has taste Cool Ranch Doritos
and Oreos I don't know if Christian
McCaffrey is doing a little daddy cigar
but I'm just telling you I was just on a
bachelor party for my guy Brad in Denver
and I the only two things that I threw
in the cart everyone's throwing in very
responsible things I was in Denver Oreos
and Cool Ranch Doritos Christian
McCaffrey sucking down egg yolks on a
Monday chomping on Oreos and Cool Ranch
Doritos on a Saturday you my friend
are the whoa big offseason eater of the
week I salute you see MC one thing I
want to do before we get to the Kevin by
yard interview which again is awesome is
there is something happening I ask you
when we were changing between Kyle
Shanahan and Sean McVeigh for our
favorite coach in the NFL which is right
now Sean McVeigh another guy that I need
to get on the podcast I'm gonna write
that down there is stock when it comes
to coaches or players and like everybody
else you want to buy stock when it's low
before it gets high all of you guys
bought stock in Sean McVeigh and I
approve the move but that's not buying
stock in Sean McVeigh is like spending
$2,000 for a share of Google that's like
that's like trying to call up Berkshire
Hathaway for a little advice but there
was a coach that I have constantly said
on the show is quickly becoming my
favorite quote in the NFL I am a super
fan geo and I think we should all be
super Fangio's because Vic Fangio member
I didn't know it was gonna is gonna dry
out my greasy Italian skin this man is
incredible two quotes from Vic Fangio
the Denver Broncos when asked about
Chris Harris's contract situation he
said quote I stay out of it that's the
business side of football I deal with
football business he is just the most
football guy football coach ever an old
Italian coach I love it
his other quote though I loved know a
fan who you know I loved tight end out
of Iowa that destroyed the combine Vic
Fangio said that Noah fan quote he's got
tools but you know I can go into Home
Depot and walk out with a bunch of nice
tools and I'm not a carpenter Vic Fangio
went [ __ ] Tommy Boy and nobody caught
it you know I can get a hell of a look
of a good t-bone steak by sticking my
head up a bull's ass but I'd rather take
the butcher's word for it he went Tommy
Boy
he went Chris Farley like freaking out
at the at the dining room table Vic
ngo I'm telling you buy stock Denver is
gonna turn it around a little bit this
season and that defense is gonna open up
a lot of people's eyes
I'm just saying call up your bookie if
you're using that app acorns find a way
to buy stock in Vic Fangio enough of me
let's get to the main man himself
all-pro safety Kevin bye art interviewed
them down there in Atlanta awesome
conversation and again after you listen
hop on the Twitter hop on the Instagram
hit up my man Kevin buy art and say
thank you for coming on the left go show
you are the [ __ ] man treat him with
respect he came in our house and you
know how the 33% does I'll holler at you
guys next week it's gonna be a lot of
fun be well keep eating like a homie
enjoy the interview welcome to the left
go show it was very dramatic I got with
me today in all-pro a man that led the
NFL for a season with eight
interceptions a man that was under
drafted going in the third round first
bigoted dirt first pick in the third
round and now in a beautiful [ __ ]
situation in a contract year on a team
that has playoff aspirations
Kevin buyer of the Tennessee Titans yes
sir glad to be here man
and you were born in Philadelphia yes I
was which has a special place in my
heart okay you move down to Georgia
Reggie I moved to Georgia with the high
school down here in Atlanta at MLK high
school so how much Philadelphia got into
your system a lot I mean my entire
family still up there my dad's still up
there so uh every too often I try to get
up there I'm just gonna try to get her
there this year hopefully maybe fourth
of July or something like yeah got to go
up there see my grandma go see all my
family go Spence
everybody's Eagles fans so you know when
you know when the Eagles came to town
last year I had my family down here they
wore their Eagles jerseys in our family
section
stop so you know they were salty going
home so you know it sounds like as a
player that
you're you share a name and blood but
they're still gonna rock the Eagles
Jersey hey I mean something you can't
control like I said all my of course my
dad he had my jersey on okay but uh you
know all my family members my uncles
they had the Eagles jerseys on there and
arguing with Titans fans and the
understands or whatever so why I'm
really good at tease them at the end of
the game well I'll tell you what that
was in my mind more the worst Eagles
games of the year what you guys did to
come back in the game right what was it
fourth and 20 you guys got a completion
on a real good completion but they may
be you guys completely shut down that
offense in the second half and overtime
yeah I mean that's that's kind of what
we did all last year honestly I mean we
we had we had a great defense last year
I mean honestly I think most of the
playoff teams that we played you talked
about the Eagles talking about the
Patriots and different teams like that
we beat a couple playoff teams last year
so hopefully we kind of take that to the
next step and actually get into the
playoffs again to the tournament this
year not only that you had against
another I don't know if the Texans still
make the playoffs
what 66 yard touchdown pass
Oh against Houston now it wasn't as
Houston I think I know it was against
Houston a week to you I didn't realize
you owned the longest touchdown pass by
a defensive player in the in history in
the Super Bowl era did you know that it
was the longest yeah you know of course
I had a bunch of Twitter messages and
stuff like that telling me but like it's
definitely a cool moment just one of
those things where got the right look
coach gave me the cue you know saying
throw a touchdown
here's what's so funny about you you
have that play you have an all-pro you
have the moment where you get on the
star and you do all that and I still
think that not enough people know who
Kevin Baier it is do you agree with me I
mean I would definitely say so but you
know at this point in my career you know
none of us everybody matters at this
point you know I'm just kind of focused
on my team trying to win a Super Bowl
yeah I think about you win a Super Bowl
man everybody and the country's gonna
know who we are so that's kind of my
focus my aspirations on you know getting
that big championship ring who do you
study
who did you study growing up like when
you were looking to be a safety who are
the guys it's funny so you know I start
off playing quarterback in high school
in the first day my coach told me I was
gonna have to play safety I went to
youtube and I typed up Brian Dawkins
weapon then yes Brian doc is but I was
always I was a Pittsburgh bang going
- so hello Polamalu always loved every
who grew up in the era of safeties ya
Mala Mala read Dawkins era was the best
probably one of the three greatest
safeties to have a play together in my
opinion it's all of a second time all at
the same time all great play about ten
years of peace so I mean it's just great
to see those guys and like I said I
emulated those guys when I got to
college I had a guy named Earl Thomas
yeah you know I had some film my coaches
office I used to watch him love watch
him go sat on the sidelines chasing the
rock man who do you think your plate
like if you if people are looking at
your play right now who do you think
your style is most reminiscent of like
who did you take the most from honestly
I would say nobody I don't really I'm
not really into the comparisons I don't
really feel like nobody really has my
game I feel like I can place I'll on the
sidelines back during the post I can get
down in the box and get dirty and I also
completes the quarterback so I don't
really think I think I have a lot of
different people in me but I don't
really say nobody but it compares to me
well I'm gonna say this and this is very
selfish
I hope Titans drop a bag on your
doorstep but if not the Eagles are
needing a safety in a year hey man like
I said man come home we're gonna bring
it home you bring your cool supreme
shirts and your off-white and we can
hang out and Philadelphia yeah yeah I
mean it would be good because like I
said being my family but at this point
right now I love the Titans I love
Nashville I wanted I want to finish my
career in Nashville's great you know
it's just a great city a great time to
play football and I love the way the
city's going this building you should
see it right now for the draft right now
you got all these cranes going up like
that so it's a great city and I would
love to be in Nashville my question for
you is this I have an agent when it's
time for my contract to be up I'm torn
between let me do my job and I want to
know what the last talk was what did you
say to your agent for this upcoming
season like to get your mind right like
what what lines did you guys establish I
won't really sales any lines
establishment I think those things kind
of play yourselves out you know as time
goes on when free agency hit he already
had some clients that he had to work on
the tank like that so I just told him I
listen man I don't even really want to
talk about it I want to come back focus
on football and if something happens
something happens if you don't then I'm
completely fine with it you know
feel like I'm blessed either way it goes
well you're like I said you're in an
amazing situation to come out like you
did the benefit of going first pick in
the third round is there's one last year
on that rookie deal and this is the
players podcast I want everyone to get a
bag when Russell Wilson got 65 on the
signing bonus right and did his little
y'all got to go to bed with Ciara like
hilarious he can talk like that right
right I believe that this is the year of
Russell Wilson
you know how Steven Urkel had Stephon I
believe but we're now in Russell Wilson
yeah Russell's a key zagging different
right now right you see a man debate
with the chainsaw it man that was pretty
awesome
his hair is different he's dressing up
nice all right it's incredible what a
good woman can do to a man now you write
about every man needs a powerful woman
behind yes everybody shout out to your
wife both shout out to my fiance the
star were you inspired by tea oh did you
know you were gonna do it like what was
the thinking behind it cuz when I google
you like 9 out of 10 or about the
[ __ ] star right crazy
yeah it's funny so it was kind of one of
those it just kind of happened in the
moment was like sort of pregame I was
just like man hey listen don't make a
big play a meet me in 50 maybe I didn't
finish so it wasn't like I was just
playing a week before it was just like I
was super excited for the game is Monday
night it's such a cool stadium yeah it
was a dope play and it was crazy so like
as soon as I caught the pig
I pointed straight at the Stars I'm
going straight to the star and like I
said it was something that kind of just
came up of course you know variable and
none of the coaches like that as well
and I you know I had to talk with him
about it so how did that conversation go
I'm afraid ball could still play right
now nah for sure very well I mean he
gets he gets down and dirty with players
on in practice even pregame and stuff
like that but you know he just kind of
told me that you know he just wished out
it came and turned around you know
excited guy decided with my teammates
went to the sideline things like what
did you say back I say yeah I won't be
dancing on star again i total net yeah
yeah no more I know out of the way
operations afterwards don't ask for
permission I know what I mean right
right the thing we our society is so
funny because we want everyone to be
like Barry Sanders mm-hmm but like when
are you ever gonna like you might not
have that opportunity again like you
might not play in Dallas Stadium for
another eight
with the way the schedules and calendars
work out and then when you play the
cowboy it might be in Tennessee so and
it's not even about marketing it's not
about branding it's like life is about
experiences - yeah and honestly I wasn't
even thinking about know how I was gonna
affect this or was it gonna pop up ones
TV I mean I kind of figured that
afterwards but it was just kind of lost
things I kind of get caught into the
game I'm grew up passing the guy who's
you know and I made a big players like a
man let's celebrate let's go that's what
I told the guys let's go dance in the
middle of the field that's kind of my
thing as a team dance in the middle - so
what is it like to stand on the star and
to have 80,000 people around you and
they're upset because you made up what
was those seconds like take me to those
seconds I mean it was awesome honestly
when I first got submit are kind of peek
behind me because I was thinking
somebody was gonna hit me and not
worried about just like I was like yeah
I was like someone's gonna knock me off
the star of course Bryan Jones or Byron
Jones came and pushed us off or whatever
but it was exciting but honestly it was
more exciting it was a lot more better
the fact we won the game it was I had to
come down there get a big one on Monday
night yeah so that was definitely the
most exciting thing about everything i I
think a lot of people thought here come
the Titans after that game you guys came
out there Derek Henry finally kind of
burst onto the scene again you guys went
out there shut down that offense I think
that game prompt did they have a more
Akua at that time yeah they did but it
was like the first day that might have
been his first game yeah so but you guys
went out there Marcus had a phenomenal
game and then it didn't finish maybe the
way that you guys were hoping how do why
do you have confidence that this year
it'll be a full year because the Texans
came the Eagles game the Patriots game
the Cowboys game you guys had some games
that went oh they can compete with
anybody right how do we get that for a
whole year yeah I think last year I mean
we were incredibly we were consistently
inconsistent know we'll have a good game
then we'll have a bad game a good game
bad game and that's something we've been
talking about just this offseason about
how do we go from good to being great
you know even if you're walking down the
hallway somebody asked how you're doing
you know you say I'm good no I'm great
cuz you know I'm saying we're kind of
trying to drill in your mindset
everything we're gonna do we're gonna
try to be great at it and uh and I think
we have we have a great team I think we
have a great
defense we have a great office so like I
said it's all about taking that next
step and whatever we have to do to do it
I think a lot of it has to do it you
know we had a new coaching staff yeah I
think a lot of reasons why you know some
teams fail just absence of trust being
able to trust each other trust the
coaches and now we have another year in
the system another year with the coaches
so we're developing that trust and that
trust I feel like it's already been
developed so now it's about taking that
next step in taken to the next level so
even getting that sort of met when you
have a coach that actually bald what's
the difference like what what does it
give you guys that a coach that didn't
play I made just different level respect
I mean you know he's been there done
that he's been in the locker room he's
had he's had those locker room
conversation he's been on the field he's
been through a training camp I'm pretty
sure Trendkill was way harder back then
than it is now so it's just a level of
respect and so you kind of trust what
he's saying he kind of been there done
days when Super Bowls yeah so it's easy
to get behind a guy like that well was
there ever a moment in the locker where
he was given a speech for you're like he
is so amped up right now like was there
with her a moment honestly is like that
every single day I mean he gets in front
of team meeting
he gets in front of team and he he has
that voice that just carries like that
leadership role and someday you know
soon as you talk everybody's listening
you know I'm saying one thing I respect
for him he holds everybody accountable
from the top to the bottom from the
quarterback to myself to anybody on the
team he's gonna hold you to the same
standard as you will undrafted guy or
practice guy I practice squad guy so
that's Sunday everybody loves about him
and definitely shows respect take me to
the Thursday night Jacksonville
balls on the one-yard line Derrick Henry
gets the ball what happened afterwards
was an absolute massacre I've never seen
a running back do that to not just a
defense right but to the Jaguars defense
what was what was your view where were
you take me through what you saw you
know we're sitting Messiah of course I'm
saying with my DBS and uh it's funny
because ever since I've been drafted
here me and Derrick came in the same
class Derrick always breaks a long run
every year he always gets like a 60 I'll
run him something like that but that run
right there once he broke it slow okay
he stiff-armed AJ you know I'm say he's
probably gonna get tagged about 250 and
got another stiff arm didn't know that's
when you're are you already on your feet
jumping up demo Oh
he's about to go he's about to go now
honestly that probably the most exciting
football player I probably seen in my
entire life to see a guy that size
taking off 99 yards yes didn't even look
this funny thing is dairy doesn't look
like he's running that fast when he's
moving and so he just stayed away from
everybody
that guy's a athletic he's he's he's a
freak of nature honestly when it's a
division rival and a division rival that
honestly the type of kind of on the
jaguars for the last few years
yeah what does it make it more special
especially because that defense talks so
much [ __ ] right yeah I mean most
definitely like I said it's kind of one
of those games where you know I think
that's always on our schedule you got
Jackson feels kind of like a rivalry
game almost in every single game you
know kind of get a little trash-talking
a little bit the week with certain guys
uh you might hear KC make a statement or
two or something like that but uh it's
always an exciting game you know was
gonna be a defensive battle it's gonna
be like a bloodbath so yeah you don't
really expect it to be high-scoring so
you go into the game why hey man we got
to play good run defense we can't let
these guy get any big plays so that's
always our man's hardly going to
Jacksonville or even if Jacksonville
comes home I'm sorry that bortles wasn't
there anymore I'm just being a dick but
I mean like come on bro right like that
team I'm talking [ __ ] you don't have to
join in I'm talking to this left come
show Jacksonville is so talented and
they were winning despite him for two
years like I have to imagine that when
you guys were watching the film you're
like I mean this could be pick city you
had to be I mean you know me I always
have a certain level of confidence it
gets honestly any quarter Bay yeah you
know but even you know or so yeah I mean
I mean I give him his respect man he led
those guys to the AFC Championship game
some that I haven't been before so uh
hopefully we understand that I'm saying
this footballs the ultimate [ __ ] team
game right all right like sometimes
coleus Campbell leads you to the AFC
Championship game like we give these
credit to the quarterbacks all the time
like they're doing everything and it's
like okay when you through 11 passes
like no I think it's Jalen Ramsey and AJ
Bailey you know I mean yeah I would
definitely say that I mean deacons def
is gonna win championships you can look
at in the Superbowl you didn't get a
high score in Super Bowl game as well so
I mean anytime you have to I mean it has
to be a team thing you can't just
handle that well I talk to a lot of
Sheriff you can't just have a great
quarterback in an asari defense it's not
gonna do anything you're just gonna sell
a bunch of tickets and didn't get to the
playoffs you're gonna lose in the first
round second round so you've experienced
a lot of markets now I hear that he's
gaining weight to do that the thing that
I love about Marcus is I feel like he's
really letting himself out there now
when I see him get that play against
Jacksonville and stand up or catch his
own touchdown in the play all right the
thing that sucks is he could play
amazing and then miss the next week
which sucks right where do you think we
are how do you think Marcus is doing and
what do what is something about Marcus
that we don't know that shows how tough
this guy actually is right I mean even
going back to that Jacksonville game
that play he made and went up a barrier
church that was uncharacteristic of
Marcus long never see and he kind of
showed a little bit of that
competitiveness competitiveness yeah but
uh I think Marcus is doing great man
like I said I see him every single day I
know how hard he works every single week
to even make sure that his body is good
throughout the year and I mean he went
through a lot of injuries last year and
that's something unfortunate something
like you walked by the training room and
you see the pain he's in like is it is
that man battling and we just don't see
it yeah and that's that's one thing
about Marcus man like I said he's better
through injuries but he's not gonna
he thought he doesn't show it like that
cuz he's such a competitor he wants to
be out there with his teammates he wants
to play in every single game but like I
said man it's there's one thing I
learned from very when he talks about it
all the time is a hundred percent injury
rate in the NFL you're gonna get injured
at some point and but one thing that I
think most guys don't know about Marcus
man he just has some type of magic about
him she's like you said throwing the
touchdown to himself catching it I mean
if you even seen last year we played
against the Giants man and dared Henry
bounce to run and he literally like had
a lead block man laid over tree out like
shoulder into him and this is no injury
come back for injury and all that
putting his body on the line for it for
his guy so I mean that's the guy that I
would always defend somebody that I
always wanted to be my quarterback
because I know for a fact he's gonna
live and die on that field for you and
that's something you know if I'm gonna
do the same thing for him so not
something doesn't being our quarterback
uh are you the biggest Drake fan ever I
don't say the biggest Dre fingers I've
been because like 90% of your captions
IG are like Drake lyrics yeah I love
dream having listened to Dre since from
the beginning so yeah obviously I'm I
definitely a drape man
Oh best album is what take care easy
that means I got a lot of great albums
and it's hard to compare a lot of funny
about Drake is is like if you put all
his songs on there and you go oh he's
pretty good and then you see all of the
hits and that doesn't even include the
features and it's like overwhelming
Drake has a lot of his I mean he's
definitely if they got a Hall of Fame
for rappers he's definitely gonna be in
a Hall of Fame for sure like he's
probably one of the top three
honestly I don't about all-time but he's
definitely top three in the game right
now for sure um I was like looking
through some of your career
accomplishments and I realized that your
first sack was on Aaron [ __ ] Rodgers
yeah my first start to I think was week
ten what was the guy what was that like
because I'm sure you watched film of
them all week what are we up against day
game was I mean I ain't you think about
it again we actually blew the Packers
out that game like beat him like over
two touchdowns or whatever but just
getting that sack on Aaron Rodgers a
legend I got up and I didn't even know
what to do I was just so excited I just
threw my arms up I just got a super
excited but like I said was my first
start it was a I think it was kind of
coming on coming into my own a little
bit and uh I had a good game that gaming
kind of took off from there
can you explain to people that maybe
don't watch film or don't have to play
on the field why Aaron Rodgers is so
special I would have to say you know a
little bit of a patch of my own special
like just the way he can just torque his
arm and throw different passes uh I mean
he's just he's so cerebral I mean I'm
pretty sure he calls his own play
sometimes at things like oh no no he
does it came out he is all his own place
I mean then you see that that update the
game already played the Bears where he
messed up his knee and he stayed in
through a long bond for a touchdown on
me that's something special you got to
really appreciate those kind of things
like I think sometimes we have a way of
not appreciating guys until they're gone
yes that guy he's a legend you know I'm
sorry I was trying to convince the
homies my listeners that I have a thing
the greatest quarterback that we've ever
seen okay it's not about titles it's
about the ability to play the position
and for years it's been Aaron Rodgers
the greatest quarterback we've ever seen
I tried to ask them this year to switch
it to Patrick mahomes is the greatest
quarterback we've ever seen and they
told
me it's too soon but I believe that
Patrick can do things that no one else
can in the history the NFL has ever been
able to do right am I crazy or am i onto
something uh you might be onto something
I want to say you crazy I would say it's
always gonna be an argument between the
two I mean Patrick my Holmes what he did
last year
you know honestly my preseason of my
second year and we played them in the
fourth game and of course he wasn't
starting Thomas Alec Smith there and I
think he started maybe the entire game I
didn't play so I was able to watch and
sit on nine and he bombed it's like
three times for over 60 yards and I'm
looking like this dude is gonna be the
truth yes so I mean I wasn't even
surprised what he did last year I mean
of course some of the highlight throws
the no-look pass I've never seen that
before
I haven't seen it in high school so I
actually around Final Four I got a
chance to like I met him we were hanging
out and I was like man that's crazy he
goes I do it all the time he goes that
was just the first time they caught me
on camera he goes I don't even think
that was my best tour of the game and I
was like oh was that other one where you
kind of threw it he can throw balls that
just like levitates over the ground
that's how strong is all that form it's
any platform and I guess and as a former
quarterback you can appreciate that yeah
most definitely I said I was lefty so
sometimes if I had [ __ ] no sling it
out there a little bit but I mean he you
could say he got that baseball in him
that he can throw from any platform and
like I said it's special because most
times you know you have a teach
quarterbacks you know go over there you
know comb the hair or something like
this I mean to be able to like I said
put his team in position to be able to
run around scramble and do all the
things he did and I think you do for
like 50 touchdowns or something like
that I mean it's just incredible how
excited do you get when you saw the
safety market and free agency this year
just to bring it back to that from this
point two years ago Safety's got nothing
right and I got really concerned about
the position because there were all
these top guys and nobody got paid and
there were all these articles being
written that the safety is a dying
market right Landon Collins Tyrann
Mathieu eric berry earl thomas so many
guys this year was it a relief was it
excitement yeah i mean first of all i
was excited to see guys like Landon
Collins and Earl Thomas get paid there
in my agency and a of course Landon life
for God has been working on his whole
life your
the Derman james david Malagueta life
safety taking over the hell yeah but I
mean it was exciting because like I said
man it's kind of weird to see you know
people talk about saying to safety the
safeties has been devalued you can't
have a good defense water gets a name
any good defenses there's ever been
without any good all-time great safety
I'm not gonna come home without it
exactly so I mean you have to have a
good guy back there in the back end
because I think one of the things that
you can talk about being a good defense
is lemonade in big place so if some if
some do break off a run breaks out or a
guy catches the ball for torn because I
mean God's gonna make place to get paid
to but you got to be able to eliminate
big plays and eliminate touchdowns and
be good in the red zone be able to
communicate and do all those different
things you can have a guy back that it
just can't 'talking it was quiet
yeah and I'm saying so having a good
safe in the back in that defense is
almost as important as having a my paint
having a pass once again sex honestly
because it's all about getting turnovers
when you guys face the Patriots in the
playoffs they it seemed like we're very
good at rushing to the line and using
your guys communication against you you
guys are a very talkative defense before
every play you're setting everything up
right and did it feel like they they
were like they talk a lot let's take
advantage of that did you feel that most
definitely I mean and that's that was my
first time really having a true
experience of Tom Brady playoff Tom
Brady too as well is it a different guy
that was my first time playing you know
like I said I mean he came out there you
know they got him out there he runs out
the tunnel with the jay-z music and it
was like oh man this is real and it's
funny because you know our defense
according to begged in Dick LeBeau short
update isn't maybe Tom Brady was written
42 years old yes I faced maybe Tom Brady
8 for 9 time playing against him so I
mean I think he probably went back to
some old film and back when I was
playing to distillers back in the day
just watching filming yeah if you see my
he had our number every single Tommy he
almost knew his egg was gonna run
switching the run this way stringing
this way dump it off here touchdown
yeah he's like aw man it's like oh here
we go again who's almost a thing that I
feel that when you play the Patriots
it's almost better to be simple because
they'll use your your complexities again
because they'll motion the tight end and
then they'll put the running back out
there right and you're trying to figure
that out and he's like it's a [ __ ]
slam but you just shifted your defense
eight times because I
right yeah no most definitely like I
said Tom Brady just has a way to you
know his mich matches and he understands
how to get guys get a running back on
the linebacker and get all these
different things but I mean this year
like I said or last year we have good
success against them who's able to
confuse him a little bit confuse the
defense I mean offers a line you know
you know we got a cup of sex on him we
had him duck in a little [ __ ] last year
so he was throwing off his back foot a
ton yeah yeah is it nice that Gronk's
gone does that change the their whole
offense you think uh or you think
they'll still find a way
I paid else because what's interesting
about Brady is when you look at him
statistically you could take away Randy
Moss right you could take away all the
wide receivers the one guy that
statistically statistically changes
Brady is Gronk he goes from like eight
yards an attempt to like 6.5 so it goes
from like Russell Wilson to Josh Rosen
right which is enormous so that's why
I'm I'm curious what's gonna happen with
them this year yeah I am too but I mean
it knowing Tom Brady man he wants he
wants to verbose before Gronkowski true
so uh I think he will find a way like I
said I think they'll reach to their
office a little bit in he always like I
said he know how to get those Mitch
matches man if he's gotta throw it to
his running back 100 times James White
and I think that's what I have to do to
get to get the chains moving I think
he'll do that you had a 1 pick and you
led to a Motown celebration I think it
was yeah yeah
which NFL team that youth do you think
has the best team celebrations team
celebrations because last year I thought
defensive guys running to the end zone
and taking a photo everybody know yeah I
got it
New Orleans started it I saw the Jets
too and I saw you doing every team does
Eagles do it right who do you think
though that you respect team
celebrations
I like the Chicago Bears Thunder braces
last year when Eddie Jackson was getting
those pick sixes oh man he was going to
August er and then yeah that was dope I
was like man I was kind of jealous look
I said those guys are having a lot of
fun last year is it time to retire the
defensive team photo I think it is I
mean it's just funny because I think
that's kind of just like the the default
one which slows my catch big all this
all comes to the end zone cuz the end
zone and everybody goes like this
exactly is that guy think it's time for
everybody to get a little bit more
creative yeah so I mean we'll see man
hopefully like I said we can get some
pick sixes we can get a lot more
interception that we did last year and
we'll have some some real nasty team
celebrations who were the defensive guys
that you notice during crossover film
that you've grown to be a fan of who
else in the league or have you become a
fan of I mean I like Darren James a lot
yeah you know he was a rookie last year
I mean that guy was all over the field
like I said cuz a lot of times you get a
lot of safeties or guys that can only do
one thing you got to be in line of
scrimmage you got to be here you got to
be there just watching him being able to
play in the post I seen a plan to post
one time against Tyree - it made a big
play in the back of it was the first
game of the year right Patrick had
already had like three touchdowns and he
threw like a 60 70 yard bomb right and
Derwin went full horizontal smacked it
out of the what was dope man so to see
him being able to play to post and I
mean he's a monster in the Box blitzing
and doing things liked it I think he's
gonna be a special player in his league
Derwin had a good dunk this offseason
Devante had a pretty good Davante Adams
had a pretty good dunk I've been
starting up the who's the best dunker in
the NFL is there anyone that I don't
know of that you've seen throw it down
that needs credit or best basketball
player in the NFL overall I've seen
Jesse and Jalen Ramsey dunk a little bit
okay so he lives in that he's long is
that guy still up there a little bit so
uh my knees almost destroyed right but
like I said I've seen highlights the
Derwent as well get out there and play
some good boss so I would like to see
both of them go up against each other
yeah - King you know I'm saying get a
little one-on-one that's what I want to
start I want to start rivalries I want
to start like Derwin versus Jalen like
one-on-one pay-per-view yeah first to 11
go ahead promote it man listen man
Derwin Jalen if you watching if you're
here you want to see y'all one-on-one
man we want to yes and you'll be a ref
yeah beat a breath man I'm not gonna
wear his black and white supreme as I
try to get dunked on man you know if I'm
a referee when you did the star Deion
Sanders kind of came after you on
Twitter yeah has that been resolved are
we good yeah more did it or did you just
let it go and he hasn't actually
apologized yet cuz like I wasn't a big
fan of that Deion right oh that was kind
of [ __ ] up I love prime right but he
was he I don't even think he realized
you were playing yeah that's kind of
what I said I think you know players
make mistakes you know I'm saying I
don't think he really understood what
was going
so you haven't got an apology I'm not
even looking for an apology I'm looking
for an apology you need to apologize to
Kevin bye art okay
you tweeted and you didn't even realize
he was a player yeah I mean I got a lot
of respect for Dionne as a player man
can you not I think you know sometimes
is you get on TV as a reporter you know
you see Stephen they submit made a
couple mistakes last year his way I mean
that guy's the awesome reporter you did
great with what he does yeah like I said
I got respect for both of those guys I
think Steven Naismith is magical no I
think a lot of people get annoyed by
Stephen a I've never seen somebody yell
and use such big words right all make
sense that's what I'm saying he's a
legend mammi deserves to get paid what
he's about to get paid or if he already
got it or whatever is so I call this the
players podcast who do you believe is
the most popular reporter amongst NFL
players my thought was that it's Joe
Xena right now okay just because I feel
like any time she's the one that
interacts with the players the most yeah
would you agree with that yeah I would
definitely say that I mean just watching
her interviews and things like that how
she talks to players and I think he's
real authentic and genuine so I have to
agree with you on that one I'm looking
at your division Texans you know
Deshawn Jaguars nick foles you guys
Mariota you just picked up Tannehill and
then who's the other team that I'm
missing in your division you said you
say Indy and your luck yeah Angela and I
was saying all that to get to the Colts
right it felt like they changed
drastically
right was what was it like on the field
with that offensive line and a healthy
luck like you didn't have that the first
two years your plan not at all I mean
honestly in my opinion we had the most
competitive division in football right
now I mean if we talk to bottom I think
every team can make it to the playoffs
and I think this was definitely gonna
make it down the stretch it's gonna be I
think you play Houston the last game so
I'm pretty sure it's gonna have some
playoff implications as well so I mean
Andrew Luck man to see him come back
from being out of football for entire
year they sure they shirt up they hold
on with big Quintin Nelson he's a beast
as well he's a big boy right there but
uh you know I think they're gonna be
very competitive and uh we'll see them
coming to Nashville a week to man I
haven't beat Andrew Luck since I've been
the lead
so there's something right he's like
undefeated its undefeated I think he's
like 10 enou against the Titans and
that's something that we have to get off
do you guys talk about that yes I know I
just go up on the board like it'll go up
on the board but I noted on the [ __ ]
board then my deviation courses my DB
coach said it the other day he say you
know he wake up in the morning he says
his prayers and he comes in is like how
can I get better today and how can I be
Andrew hook yeah so I mean we definitely
got it you know said we got a haunted
you cuz that's his thing if he interacts
yeah yeah most definitely I mean he's
such a nice guy is it's kind of hard to
talk you know I'm saying that in the
game's gonna hate me I love you I love
you again you're a great player and
stuff ladies like man come on I want to
say something say so much so I could say
something back to you but Bart Scott
told me that the one player he was
actually afraid of was Larry Allen and
Bart talked a lot of [ __ ] but he said
this is a man that can bench 500 pounds
and grew up in Compton is there any
offensive player that you purposely do
not want to talk trash because they're
just that physically imposing there's a
lot of offensive linemen out there that
are tough you got one on your team yeah
Milan that won't smoke is my guy but is
there anyone that you face that you're
kind of like oh I don't I don't really
need to get pinned to the ground by that
guy right I will quit Nelson would
definitely be on maybe high on that list
I mean just watching him last year that
guy's so strong and big I think maybe
he's bench pressing 500 pounds but I
remember my rookie year uh-oh similarly
he just got traded lunch on the Raiders
and on the Jets
I remember my rookie year man I was
coming to box to fit to run and he was
pulling and I kind of got caught behind
the eight-ball man and he literally did
this and I flew like five yards and I
end up injuring my own teammate he
sprained his ankle and he was mad at me
for that but I was like man that guy is
huge and big so that's something I
definitely want to see pulling around
there's no man he's just like yeah I
even say no there's nothing he just went
right back and lined up and that's why
that's the worst when you get somebody's
literally just lines back out don't say
that's how Quinn Nelson is nobody say
too much he's gonna line up hit you line
up and hit you again is not a machine
exactly camera to get to their hands a
little bit um wide receiver that when
you're defending the post you're just
like I got I got to get on it like it's
it's gonna be a track meet I would say a
bee man we play a bee
yeah I thought you're gonna say Tyriq
Tower Hill was one of those - yeah but
what is it about a bee man a beach is a
different cat man up dangers his work
ethic you know you see I hear that but
I'm asking you during the game right
what is it about AD that makes him such
a tough cover I mean he just always
moving she's like a jitterbug and it's
like he's always trying to get open and
I mean one thing that I knew when he was
with the Steelers Brownsburg was always
looking for him hmm so it's like you
know if you have a post safety you
better make sure you're leaders but I
feel like he's lost a step
you think so in terms of straight-line
speed right like I think if you just if
he threw a god I got a deep balls last
year though but I think Ben's one of the
greatest deep ball throws the game has
ever seen like he drops it in there
agree with it but I think a be like when
he was younger he was a lot faster abies
quickness is unbelievable and his
ability and his awareness on the
sideline like his ability to go down
that like he opens up parts of the field
that other wide receivers don't because
they can't do those things right but I
just I always get surprised because I go
you're I think you're faster than
Antonia Brown we had the race we'll have
to see I think I can talk anybody pretty
much maybe except for Tyreke you know
maybe but he's unbelievably don't
believe but with a B you're just saying
he's got everything in the chamber yeah
he's just a complete player I mean for a
god it may not be you know 6-1 6-2 I
mean he'd like to say he's a jitter but
he can run every single route and like I
said I'm pretty sure oaken's gonna
develop a lot of different plays and
kind of sees what he likes to do I mean
you just know how to get over me he's
always over the NFL starting to get a
little bit MBA ish in terms of the
offseason yeah this felt like an NBA
offseason yeah Antonio Brown got a gold
mustache and pretty much got himself
traded uh-huh Odell out of nowhere
traded to the land of LeBron Cleveland
and then I'm seeing a levy on goat it
was it was interesting right when the a
B thing was happening I'm at home eating
popcorn and this is crazy
what was it like in the NFL world
watching this guy kind of do all these
things what was it like to see I mean
honestly it was a wonder of course he
kept everybody know checking their
phones and stuff like that but I think
this was a that's what happens in this
game when you have
you know star players you know I'm
saying at the top of the game
you know they had they just carry a
certain better power and you know I'm
saying certain things where they can you
know sometimes they can control their
own situation yeah
determine where they can go where you
know most of us can't so I'm sure what
are you you texting your teammates and
you guys like you guys seeing this right
now like was it like that level yeah I
mean like I said is if something that
everybody was watching everybody was
saying uh honestly I'd say the most
surprising thing was saying oh they'll
get traded to Cleveland to I'm saying
that's that kind of broke everything I
feel like I just caught a flight and I
just got back in the house and and I
seen on my phone I ran into the TV cut a
TV like he's real is this real like it
was crazy him Jarvis and Joe ku week one
Nick that's who you play week week or
anchor uh-huh
you realize the attention that's gonna
be on that game they've become like the
most interesting team in the NFL to a
lot of people they said a tick is up and
their ticket prices doubled since last
year my de median ticket prices doubled
already and you get to watch their film
for the next like four months to get
ready tell me about that holy crap yeah
I'm super excited like I said last time
I played Jarvis man when he was in Miami
he was talking a lot of trash as well so
I'm excited to play him again he's I
think he's probably one of the best slot
receivers in lis and not only the best
receiver just blocking receiver as well
he's super aggressive and have Odell and
right next to him and Baker and the boys
and he's gonna be super excited cuz like
I said me us as a DB man we kind of have
our own little thing MMC and be my man
catches no boss so we're gonna be super
excited so me it's gonna get real
competitive week one I'm pretty sure
it's gonna be a sold-out so - because
y'all know they're gonna try and take a
shot - Odell oh yeah early I'm like I'm
thinking I'm thinking flea-flicker right
I'm thinking really like like Odell's
the one receiver and they got like three
tight ends and it's like a play-action
like they're gonna want to go over this
and Maggie's in Cleveland or Tennessee
is in Cleveland that's one of you are
entering the Lions Den listen last time
I was in Cleveland I caught three
interceptions
so uh in one game shout-out to Sean
kinda so like I said it's gonna be super
excited and I'm pretty sure Baker's
gonna be watching a film with me as well
so yeah if you can get it over the top
man on Glam glad to see him try it you
know I'm saying we're gonna be super
excited yeah you got a message for Baker
what are you gonna say hey listen ma'ams
gonna let my play do to talk I say it's
a long time from there
Sam like I said it's gonna be super
excited I'm excited to play him and it's
gonna be a great game I think the cool
thing is is sometimes you get a dud on
your first week and it's it's not that
exciting you know what I mean
right but I feel like it makes the
offseason that much more exciting almost
definitely right coming straight out the
gate so you know all offseason I'm
thinking about that week one think about
Odell think about Jarvis think about
Baker and the boys and making sure I'm
doing everything I need possible and
helping bring it everybody else along as
well to understand like we have a great
opportunity and week one to go out there
and you know kind of shock shock the
world in my opinion my last thing for
you is first pick of the third round
before you had the eighth interception
season and I think everybody kind of
knew who you were after that was there
ever a moment where an opponent really
didn't know who you were and you're
played in the talking to where they felt
the need to either come up to you after
the game and say man I didn't realize or
door in the game was there ever a cool
moment like that yeah like I said I grew
up a Steelers fan so after that year I
caught all the interceptions Ben
Roethlisberger Kent's me in the game was
like man you're a great player you know
I love your game and things like that
meant a lot to me cuz like I said I've
been watching stairs ever since his
rookie year so it was pretty awesome
pretty dope and is that is that a moment
that like on the way home you're
thinking about it like like I remember
being here at Turner and like one time I
walked in and and Berkeley was like hey
Adam and I was like oh [ __ ] ya know like
you know I mean like for like two days I
was like [ __ ] of Berkeley knows my name
I'm good you know I'm sure wasn't like
that was Ben tonight I'm most definitely
my family was there I didn't get at the
game so I'm telling them like yeah if
you're honest Berg came to me said this
said this he was like man for real so
yeah he knew who you were
I said yeah man so it was pretty dope
man like I said I mean now you know I'm
swapping jerseys with a lot of different
guys who they swapped with oh what a lot
of different guys especially you mean
guys that I played with do you want to
swap with a wide receiver or with
another DB I used try to swap with DB
but at the same time before the receiver
that I respect and that I really liked
and we might swap jerseys but a not swap
jerseys with like Bashar Jones of course
Jalen Ramsay yeah
I mean hopefully I can get him more guys
that I played this year but I mean I got
I got a good little Jersey collection
for like a doll so Eric why do I swap
with him down to Provo that was pretty
Dobies I think he's gonna be a future
Hall of Famer so
he's up there yeah most definitely I
mean it'll be interesting with him at
the Rams - really it's yeah I think he I
think he'll be able to change the coach
of that defense oh my god
I think his ability to put Marcus Peters
and Hakeem to leave in the right spot
Zac I think he may lead to Marcus Peters
being an all-pro next year because if if
Weddell sets him up but Peters ability
to jump routes is so good exactly and
he's a dog and so if what'll goes you
know watch the flat right and beaters
can only worry about that he might he
might have a Pyxis yeah I think that's
what's so underrated about safes and you
got a guy like wet oh you know he's it's
not only just to own the play field and
stuff that you may have own Edel's
Weddell slowing down and stuff like that
but a guy so smart he's a great leader
he brings everybody along and that's
that's so underrated when it comes to
say that you can have a guy that's back
there that sees everything oh man that's
so Surrey was so smart man like I said
could change the defense you see how
good Baltimore has been in the past few
years all right so if I put you this is
my last last one so I apologize to
everyone recording this your free safety
you're not allowed to pick Logan you're
not allowed to pick Malcolm you know
let's pick any of your teammates build
the rest of the secondary around you how
you would want your perfect secondary
not including teammates I know I can't
answer that question
that's my [ __ ] I can't go against my
guys I have no know but I'm telling you
that like you would pick them okay like
if you had your first pick you would
pick your teammates I'm saying you can't
have them so like I'm putting Ramsey on
one side okay would you agree yeah I
mean is how we're gonna pull this - ok
ok ok ok
cuz there's no drama here sir I probably
choose my guys like I said I got uh I
feel like I was choosing the guys it's
in my agency I got Casey Heyward on one
side
I got Jalen the other side you could put
a landing right next to me and I think
we'll be dope ok let's talk the agency
really quick did this just start
happening did your agent David just
start picking the right guys or like how
did it get to this point where you guys
are all under the same house it's insane
right I think I pages got more to do
with relationships you know I think kind
of started with him having an Earl and
then he kind of had I think he had land
in and then after that then he kind of
had jail in those guys in and so when
you
coming out you'll see all these safeties
in the world like oh I want to go there
so I actually was with different agency
before and after my rookie year you know
I was kind of thinking about transition
to a different agency and you know guys
come and say hey man David Malta get him
he's a really good agent he'd be
interested in signing you so I'm I
already knew I'm like man he got all
these top guys yeah and kind of knowing
that you know he has all these safeties
and all these saison great players I
want to be a part of that family
and it's cool cuz you guys like hanging
out with each other we hang out which
other I mean like say we have kidney
Vaquero who's on our team you know we
got a lot of great guys and a like I
said actually this summer we're gonna
have like a safety summit so Rob thank
you you're working out together I was
saying when Von Miller did the pass
rushing summit right they should do this
with all the positions who is heading it
up who's the safety that's kind of
leading and it's you know of course it's
gonna be Earl he's gonna be you know
these older guys so we're gonna be down
in Texas gonna be working out but you
know we got a lot of [ __ ] invite haha
I don't I just want to shoot the [ __ ]
and like get I want to get like a lot of
you guys around the table right and like
talk about the safety position the
history so tell your man David I guess I
need to talk to him because I want
safety is my favorite position
sure Brian Dawkins is all of my
passwords now my password is not Brian
talk yes it's different got to
underscore one or something like that
there may be an exclamation point there
somewhere but I think safety is the cool
like I grew up love and Ronnie a lot and
I and I loved Brian Dawkins but also
like I loved the guys like Adrian Wilson
if you remember that guy and that
Cardinals e come on amazing
i-i've always because I think it's one
of the most versatile positions in all
of sports right and I love the
quarterback in the defense and it's when
a safety lays the wood it is one of the
best because it's pure you're right I
mean when nowadays you know we give play
a little much is so hard to do it I mean
I didn't see my guy can't get flat a
couple times as well so and trying to
take that part away from the game but
you know we're all for player safety
like that but I mean like I said well
you get a guy that can hit that can
cover yeah they can and not only and
nowadays not only just cover he's got a
cover these tiny and sometimes you got
to cover some receivers in a slot right
so to be able to do as much as you can
and also had that leadership aspect it's
so far look out for my guy coming out of
Mississippi State John Abram yeah a lot
of people to listen was the top safety I
had him on the show he
is I only want to pick one guy in the
draft to be my favorite he's my favorite
okay so if you cross paths was past with
him that didn't make any [ __ ] sense
take care of him for now I'm always
definitely man I heard he's good player
great to meet you don't give me the real
[ __ ] water show it man thank you
there you go uh bye art Kevin by our
Tennessee Titans 31 31
why 31 I actually got Dee boo debo from
our College number number 20 when I was
coming out by parish Coxon yeah I had no
choice but so I'm with 31 and I made
some plays and 31 sauce lights no one
switch and everyone be on the lookout
what's your social KB underscore 31 era
and then of course I'm KB 31 Sabbath or
Instagram so hit them up let them know
they use the [ __ ] man you were the
dude you say thank you sir